anyway guys thanks for tuning into the
channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe today and become a reject
Akaka nightís oh I thought you're gonna
say reject akan and I was rejecting
Kanna night it rejected [ __ ] and itis is
something I feel I've developed over
time
it's a condition what are the symptoms
um a lot of sex you have a lot of sex
well I bet a lot of people suffer from
rejected clintonites
yeah you better believe that Veronica
suffers from reject Akaka - anyway you
can also subscribe
British whoops oh no what are your
secret superpower hearing ability
telling you something Veronica's here oh
good good no not not not not good why
Brandi I don't know why but Veronica
what why I guess the weather introduced
us I don't know how many times have to
tell you I don't know why I don't know
hey but I mean whatever it is I mean we
can work it out real talking
you really don't know Veronica do you I
guess not
yeah can you guess correctly we gotta
hide you know No shut up we gotta hide
you old I'm not gonna let another one
die tonight the closet worth hiding
place ever
I'll try to stall her as much as I can
but if she finds out you're here we're
both dead okay so I ready stop crying
we're gonna make it out of here alive
okay here hi
all right to stay hidden I'm gonna go
now okay okay I I I kind of cared about
our friendship okay
hey baby
hi Ryan how was your day this long and
stressful Ryan long stressful
I know what that's like
is that a dick joke your amazingly
kick-ass girlfriend comes home from a
long hard day at work and you greet her
with another dick joke
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you had
a long hard day I'm sorry I'm sorry
you're hiding something
where is that [ __ ] [ __ ]
deep first
I know you're here babe
come on brandy I found her busty brand
you
holy water shake weight I know what to
do I'm gonna find you
I always thought we had such a great
connection be better friends
for unto us a child is born China's is
given and the government shall be upon
his shoulder
go to hell you [ __ ]
my name is brandy price I am a demon
hunter for ten years I've been hunting
Veronica six toasts I had to win over
the loyalty of Ryan Wright and become an
honorary reject to infiltrate their home
unfortunately Ryan had to be sacrificed
in the process in order for me to
complete my mission
kill Veronica six toast now and must
leave for no one must know the truth
about the demons that are out there
good our Brandon okay oh yeah
she's feeling great
and I wanted stop by tell them you know
how much I love and appreciate them so
don't do that enough you know and
friendship and life is really precious
so nice happening get out of here
yes
I
right Ryan you're dead is dead -
[ __ ]
right Veronica both dead Ryan ronica
Ryan Veronica Veronica Ryan Ryan
Veronica Veronica Veronica Ryan Ryan
Veronica Veronica Veronica Ryan Ryan
Veronica wake up Ryan ronica bronnikov
Ryan